America begins to reopen amid good
coronavirus news Joe Biden decides that
masking is in fact his campaign strategy
and President Trump goes had it with
Twitter i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show the ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn surf the web
with peace of mind sign up right now
expressvpn comm / ben well before we
begin I just want to say thank you to
all of our advertisers who continue to
sponsor the program and thank you to our
listeners who continue to patronize our
advertisers one of those fantastic
advertisers is pure talk USA you're
spending too much on your cell phone
bill you are you're spending just too
much money on that you can't afford to
do that right now this is why you need
to go check out pure talk USA you can
cut cost and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider pure talk will cover 99% of
Americans the president and CEO of pure
talk is in fact u.s. veteran he cares
deeply about serving Americans by making
Wireless before blood met him great dude
start your saving today dial pound two
fifty and say key word ben shapiro and
you get unlimited talk unlimited text
and one gig of data for just 20 bucks a
month see one of the reasons you pay a
lot of money for your cell phone bill is
because you are paying for insane levels
of data they are never going to use
instead dial pound 250s a key word ben
shapiro and you get unlimited talk
unlimited text and one gig of data for
just 20 bucks a month plus you get fifty
percent off your first month which means
ten bucks your first month stop paying
too much too big wireless providers
switch to pure talk today save fifty
percent off your first month in again
the coverage is just as good as all the
other wireless providers dial pounds to
fifty say key word ben shapiro again
that's pound to 50 key word ben shapiro
pure talk USA simply smarter Wireless
dial to 50 pounds at 250 and say the key
word Ben Shapiro that again that's pound
to 50 key word Ben Shapiro for that
special deal okay so we have a lot of
good news on coronavirus and we actually
do so first piece of good news I mean it
doesn't sound like good news but it is
the toll of the u.s. virus deaths has
been under 700 nationwide for the third
straight day so put this in contrast
when we were at our height we were close
to 3,000 a day we were losing close to
3,000 people attend we are now down to
under 700 and to put that even more into
contrast the number of Americans who die
on a normal day is about 7500 Americans
dying on a normal day so with kovat 19
during the heat of this thing when it
was really just running roughshod
through New York you're increasing the
death rate across the country by
something
one third I mean it was an insane level
and you were seeing in New York
specifically people dying at a rate of
like four to five times what they were
normally dying of in New York seven
hundred people a day dying across the
United States it sounds bad and it is
bad obviously it's a lot of people but
in comparison to the number of people
who die daily in in the United States
generally it is certainly not on the
order of what it was and that's a very
very good thing in fact the CDC is now
releasing new information demonstrating
the infection fatality rates and the CDC
is saying that the fatality rates for
coronavirus and this is by the way for
identified cases this does not include
the asymptomatic and they say about
thirty five percent of all cases are now
asymptomatic this is what the CDC is is
now suggesting according to PJ media the
CDC is saying here's the fatality rate
for coronavirus so if you are anywhere
below the age of fifty years old your
fatality rate for coronavirus meaning if
you actually get it is 0.05 percent
point zero five not five percent not
point five percent point zero five
percent okay which is a very very low
rate right actually lower than the flu
the flu rate is 0.1% generally for all
American populations not sure what is
for people under 50 presumably would be
a lot lower than that but this is not an
extraordinarily dangerous virus if you
are under the age of 50 particularly if
you don't have a significant underlying
condition like diabetes or severe
obesity if you are 50 to 64 years old it
is a point two percent fatality rate if
you're 65 plus years old it is one point
three percent fatality rate and again
that includes everybody who's above the
age of 80 where the fatality rate is
greatly increased overall they are
saying now that the case fatality rate
is 0.4 percent or about four times as
deadly as the flu which again is a far
cry from what was original if I have
been saying this for months by the way
right I have been saying for a long time
that I thought the actual case fatality
rate on this thing was somewhere between
two point two percent 0.6% turns out
it's dead in the middle point four
percent according to the CDC according
to the CDC's current best estimate the
case fatality rate of coronavirus is 0.4
percent that's just among the
symptomatic cases the CDC estimates that
that's 65 percent of all cases which
means that if actually the case fatality
rate reward to include all of the
asymptomatic infections even according
to the CDC it would be approximately
0.26 percent point
to 6% which is really you know that that
is optimistic I mean that that is a good
number that is it when I say it's good
obviously it's bad I mean all these
numbers are bad but it is certainly not
nearly as deadly as we were originally
told we were told that it was 10 times
like 10 X maybe 15 X that rate it is not
in fact it's closer to the endpoint for
maybe 0.25 and by the way if there are
more asymptomatic cases than 35% of all
cases then you're talking about lower
than that for most group so all of this
is very good news and this is why you
are starting to see this this move by
various areas including New York and LA
toward reopening important thing to
mention when it comes to viruses like
this there are been some theories out
there one from a Hebrew University
scientists who suggested that viruses
tend to burn themselves out this this
tends to be true that the most virulent
strain of a virus burned their way
through a population and then you get
sort of weaker strains of the virus that
continue to linger on in the population
for a long period of time theoretically
that could be happening here we don't
know yet but bottom line is that
everybody now recognizes that we cannot
remain in lockdown like this not on the
basis of these statistics this is why in
Los Angeles County which has been one of
the most lockdown places in America
supervisor Katherine Barger announced
that LA County has now achieved
readiness criteria and will apply for a
variance with the state of California
tomorrow if granted the variance from
the state public health order will allow
LA County to advance further in stage 2
and into stage three of the state's
roadmap to recovery what that means is
that the county is moving toward
additional steps meaning the immediate
reopening of in-person shopping and
houses of worship that doesn't mean
there won't be social distancing and
mask-wearing there well but this would
mean that they can move beyond simply
takeout orders you can go to a
restaurant again you just have social
distance from places presumably is gonna
be the next step so all of this is
optimistic and that's good
maybe we should why should we be
downplaying good news this is good news
even Governor Cuomo New York is saying
that New York City could be reopened by
mid-june what you get is a good piece of
news according to The Wall Street
Journal he says the New York said he
could begin a phased reopening in the
first or second week of June this is
according to bill de blasio de Blasio
has headed a press conference the city
will have about 180 testing sites open
by the end of June with the expectation
to run about 50,000 coronavirus tests
daily by August first a June first goal
to hire a thousand contact tracers has
already been met and exceeded some 700
of those were
are based in the city's hardest hit
communities and speaks some 40 different
languages de Blasio says hundreds of
thousands of people will need to use
mass transit in the initial phase of the
reopening which allows construction
manufacturing and retail for curbside
pickup officials are trying to determine
how exactly they can operate the subways
and the buses without overcrowding but
the bottom line is that even New York
City is now moving toward reopening and
it's happening in New Jersey as well
according to reporter Carl Quintanilla
at CNBC he points out that 13 states
have been open for more than three weeks
now those states have now seen daily
cases fall 29 percent
29 percent over the over the prior three
weeks which is kind of incredible
because you expect actually the number
of cases to be up ticking not down
ticking right as the as the number of
people out in public Rises you would
expect again that kind of spike again
but we are not really seeing that spike
again in fact we are seeing a declining
rate of positivity across the country
father John Jenkins who's the president
of the University of Notre Dame of Notre
Dame he is suggesting that it is time to
reopen Notre Dame as a school he says
that that we are announcing plans to
return students to campus for the fall
semester in order to reduce the chance
of the students from around the country
in the world with multiple departures
and returns we'll carry pathogens with
them we'll bring students back two weeks
early for Goa Fall Break and finish the
semester before Thanksgiving they'll
conduct orientations to welcome them
back in the cove in nineteen aura
they'll Institute extensive protocols
for testing contact tracing and
quarantine preventive measures such as
hand-washing physical distancing and in
certain settings the wearing of masks
and certain settings is the key right at
Letta competition provides in other sets
of challenges they believe that they can
keep student athletes safe fans in the
stadium is is going to be a different
question but bottom line again is that
the reason markets are optimistic right
now is because people are looking at
reopening and the reopening is going to
be more Swift and I think people think
it's going to be because once you allow
people out people are going to want to
hang out with each other people are
willing to undertake the risk once they
become comfortable that we're not
spiking over the healthcare system once
they become comfortable but this is not
looking like Italy people may continue
to wear masks I can tell you in LA
people are still wearing masks they
should be right I am a mask advocate I
know there are a lot of people on the
right who believe that masks are a
terrible horrible no good very bad
things I disagree with this on a general
level I think that the science disagrees
with this the bottom line is that people
this from droplets and from prolonged
close contact with the other human
beings who have this sort of thing if
you are in a closed area with another
person within six feet of that person
you should be wearing a mask if you are
outside six feet of that person then you
probably should not be wearing a mask
where it doesn't matter if you're
outdoors it probably is not gonna matter
all that much unless you are in an
extremely extremely close contact okay
so that's where I am on the mask wearing
we'll get into the mask wearing in just
a second because this has become an
issue of contention but all of this is
very very good so why exactly are the
media trying to downplay it we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that you want to make
sure that you know everything that's
going on in your neighborhood on your
property these days the fact is the
places like LA County have been
basically letting people out of jail
with no bail and that means there's been
increased criminality in terms of easy
things like people walking up to your
mailbox and just stealing stuff well
thanks to ring comm you can actually
keep track of all of that stuff ring is
on a mission to make neighborhoods safer
their home security products are
designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock from video doorbells
and security cameras to smart security
lighting alarm systems ring has
everything you need to make sure your
family and belongings are safe and
secure anytime anywhere with the only
ring video doorbell three you can keep
an even closer eye on things than ever
before ring gives you protection at
every corner they've got the video
doorbells that let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime and
keep an eye on your doorstep speak to
delivery people when you can't come to
your door without door security cameras
you can check in on every part of your
house and never miss a moment smart
lighting brightens up blind spots make
sure that you always come home to a
brightly lit house for home security
systems give you everything you need to
protect your family pets and property
and you get a special offer on the ring
welcome kit right now when you go to
ring calm /ban that welcome kit includes
the ring video doorbell three and the
trying pro it's all you need to do to
start building custom security for your
home today just go to ring comm slash
pen again that is ring.com slash Ben go
check them out right now ok so there's
been a lot of eagerness to reopen and
the stock market is reflecting that so
I'm honestly bewildered by all the
people who are bewildered by the stock
market increase mr. ma stock market is
increasing because people are pricing
the future into the present this is
exactly what stock markets do stock
markets are designed to take all of the
knowledge and speculation about the
future and then to price that into the
stock price right this is why insider
trading is a crime because if you know
what's going to happen two days from now
you can price that into how you consume
particular stocks so why is the stock
market up some thirty five percent since
it hit the
well because we know where the bottom
was we know that there's gonna be a
recovery and people feel like they can
buy low I mean I was buying stock during
this time I was telling people not to
sell their stock during this time
because there was going to be an
increase in the stock market yeah but
this is still led people who don't like
President Trump to basically suggest
that the stock market is delusional if
the stock market is disconnected from
reality it is not disconnected from
reality the stock market tumbled from
30,000 to 18,000 during a government
mandated shutdown now as that shutdown
ends people are beginning to see the
light at the end of the tunnel they're
getting more optimistic and they're
investing in companies again which makes
perfect sense
well this led to a big blow up this
morning on CNBC Andrew Ross Sorkin who
nice guy I'm pretty friendly with him he
got into a tiff with another person
named Joe Kernan on CNBC who's been
talking up the stock market and saying
now is pretty good time to buy which is
true and ross sorkin basically suggests
that if you're talking up the stock
market right now then this is because
you are a shill for President Trump
that's just nonsense panicked about ever
going out again
panic thousand people die Joe and all
you did was try to help your friend the
president that's what you did every
single morning on this show every single
morning keep their cool keep their heads
okay again that that's just nonsense
it's bad media coverage it's bad media
coverage the reason that people aren't
talking up the stock market is because
right now is actually a fairly good time
to buy into the stock market but again
there there's a narrative that has to be
driven which is that if you're
optimistic about the future it's because
you are not taking the virus seriously
or there's another narrative that's
going around now and that narrative is
that if you're in favor of ending lock
down it's because you're vicious and
cruel
then it's because you're nasty and this
is what Andy Beshear the the governor a
Democratic governor of Kentucky is
saying there was a rally outside the the
Statehouse I guess somewhere in Kentucky
and somebody hung him in hanged him in
effigy hung him in effigy hang just for
a picture hung is for a human being they
hung him in effigy which is
a nasty ding and an ugly thing and then
Bashir basically blamed every Republican
which is just stupidity I'm sorry
no one was actually encouraging people
to hang the governor in effigy here he
was blaming Republicans for wanting to
end the lockdown because supposedly this
leads to people burning people in effigy
you cannot fan the flames and then
condemn the fire those at the previous
rally those elected officials that
embrace these individuals and that stood
in front of people dressed in tactical
gear and the rest and threw as much red
meat as possible at them they have to
claim responsibility because they
absolutely know what could have happened
and we are in part responsible for what
would that say with that said if you
were in favor of ending the lockdowns
you're not responsible for some jackass
being a jackass in front of a governor's
house that's not a thing that really is
not I'm very tired of this game this
game gets played all the time unless
you're a Bernie Sanders supporter and
she shoot up a bunch of Congress people
then obviously Bernie Sanders has
nothing to do with it
this only works one way okay so all of
this is leading to the inevitable
political conflict the political
conflict is now going to be that
Republicans supposedly don't take this
thing seriously and Democrats do take
this thing seriously this doesn't have
to be political what if I take this
seriously but I also understand the cost
to lock down what if I take this
seriously but I also believe that
America has to reopen what if I take
this seriously but I believe that the
individual Americans who live
particularly in highly populous areas
are generally responsible and they
actually don't need every single
American to be responsible in order to
keep down the transmission of the virus
because that actually happens to be the
case but this is pure binary politics
because we always revert to pure binary
politics when in doubt we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about an incredible gift for your dad
for Father's Day I'm talking about like
a bass gift for your dad for Father's
Day I'm talking about Omaha Steaks when
JJ Simon and his son immigrated to the
United States from Latvia in 1898 they
settled in Omaha Nebraska they worked as
butchers for the local community for 20
years before their business became so
successful they started distributing to
grocers hotels and distributors it was
the start of what we know and love is
Omaha Steaks Omaha's world-famous steaks
have been naturally aged at least 21
days for tenderness hand-carved to
perfection they offer tasty and easy
make side dishes artisan
desserts and much much more Omaha Steaks
has been America's original butcher
since 1917 they deliver guaranteed
quality and safety backed by an
unconditional 100% money back guarantee
all your stuff is going to arrive at
fresh right now Omaha Steaks is offering
that my listeners access to a variety of
amazing packages that are perfect to
send for Father's Day I mean these are
aged steaks to perfection like if
there's anything that makes me want to
not keep kosher as much it is Omaha
Steaks go to Omaha Steaks com enter a
code Shapiro's into the search bar to
unlock savings for my listeners up to
50% great deal and free shipping on
orders over ninety nine bucks I mean
this is amazing stuff so what exactly
can you get I mean get the caramel apple
tartlets you can get the steaks you can
get the you can get the the potatoes are
Gratton I mean just tons of amazing
amazing stuff
100% American grain finished beef
naturally aged at least 21 days they've
got the the steaks the chicken and the
pork the burger is easy to make meals
desserts and more and again all you have
to do is head on over to Omaha Steaks
com for Father's Day enter the code
Shapiro's that's Omaha Steaks com answer
Shapiro and shop for Father's Day today
a bunch of different packages available
in that unlock savings from my listeners
of up to 50% and more and free shipping
on orders over ninety nine bucks I mean
I'm getting hungry just thinking about
this right now pardon that's because
I've been up since 3:30 in the morning
with my kids but part of it is because
this all sounds unbelievably delicious
go check it out right now
Omaha Steaks comm and search for code
Shapiro okay so this obviously was going
to break down politically and was gonna
break down politically because it turns
out then when you look at the stats it's
fairly obvious who blew it and who
didn't and when you look at which
governors performed well in which
governors performed poorly it was pretty
obviously who did pretty well and who
did pretty poorly so president Trump
highlight this yesterday he said it's a
disgrace how the governor's handled
nursing homes this is a hundred percent
true a forty seven percent of all deaths
in the United States happen in nursing
homes here was Trump going after
governor's for how they treated nursing
homes which is not his fault that would
be the governor's fault we're using
every tool at our disposal to protect
our nursing homes from outbreaks he's no
the disaster of how badly some of the
governor's handled nursing homes it's a
disgrace what they've done what the
governor's what some of the governor's
have done is a disgrace our seniors are
very special people all of our citizens
are
so but our seniors would have to take
care of our seniors okay so he is
correct about this now where the
Democrats have opened up a gap is in the
idea that Trump was unserious about this
thing and that Democrats were serious
about this thing and this is why you're
saying Joe Biden trying to draw a
contrast around the issue of
mask-wearing okay so that there's all
sorts of conflict over whether masks
should in fact be mandated or whether
they should not and this is a serious
question the reason it's a serious
question is because of its mandated by
the state that means the police can come
and arrest you if you don't wear a mask
what if loose are gonna tackle you now
we've seen in New York that Bill
DeBlasio is not willing to you know
follow through on the courage of his
convictions and actually have people
tackled in in the open because they're
not wearing masks instead it's sort of
people going by and announcing that you
should wear a mask or that you should
socially distance and there are people
on the right or very much anti mask
because they believe that this leads to
a perception of a new normal in which we
are all expected to wear masks I don't
think anybody really believes that long
term we're all gonna be wearing masks I
think what people believe is that for
the moment in order to prevent the spike
of a spread in order for us to all get
back to business
we should probably wear masks to protect
the most vulnerable particularly when
the most vulnerable are there according
to CNN as more places across the u.s. to
offer people a chance to shop or dine
inside the issue of whether to wear
masks as he again become a flashpoint
there are 17 states where the number of
coronavirus cases are trending up many
governors have told citizens that now's
an important times where a face covering
Virginia on Tuesday became the latest
state to compel people to wear masks in
certain situations the rule applies to
anyone 10 years of age or older within a
public indoor space according to
governor Ralph Northam this of course
came immediately after Ralph Northam was
out in public with other people doing
photo lines and not wearing a mask so
the hypocrisy of our politicians is
something to behold from the CDC
recommends wearing a cloth face covering
in public when it is hard to stay
socially distant dr. Deborah Burt says
what we have said to people is there's
clear scientific evidence now by all
droplet experiments that happen and that
others have done to show a mask does
prevent droplets from reaching others we
need to be wearing masks in public when
we cannot social distance but some
Americans argue that this feels like a
forfeiture of freedom they're a bunch of
people who are basically implying that
that wearing a mask is foolish or it's
giving up basic American freedoms I
don't think that's right I don't think
that the state should be compelling you
to wear a mask if you are out in public
but I do think that you're not
being how to put this kind to others if
you are in a place with vulnerable
people and you're not wearing a mask at
the same time if your unmasked alone in
a car you're if you're if you're
wearing a mask alone in your car you're
stupid if you're out in public and
you're a hundred feet away from
everybody and you're wearing a mask
let's say you're at a Veterans Memorial
in Delaware and you're within 50 feet of
nobody and you're wearing a mask
that's just virtue signaling at this
point and this has become the point is
that Joe Biden wants to virtue signal
right he wants this contrast because
again the idea here is that if he wears
a mask and Donald Trump does not it's
because he takes this thing seriously
and Donald Trump does not so yesterday
Biden tweeted out just wear a mask I
mean that's literally the entire tweet
wear a mask so this is his campaign his
campaign is wear a mask as opposed to
Trump who refuses to wear a mask again
now here's the thing I think that Trump
is actually kind of foolish to see this
ground most Americans are on board with
the idea that when you are in a crowded
area you're supposed to wear a mask at
least for the moment I think that it's
it's the desire to virtue signal on both
sides is truly insane not because it's
bad to wear a mask Ian I've given you my
perspective on masks but there is a
group of people who basically spend all
day and I know the term now on the
Internet's become caring like the basic
idea is that you're gonna go around and
Karen it people I mean you're gonna yell
at people if they're not wearing a mask
and you're gonna you're gonna shame them
and make them feel bad even if they're
not endangering anybody because you're a
better than they are it's just become
another example of the sort of 1930s
style you're flying the blue eagle that
means you're loyal to the government as
opposed to you're not wearing a mask
that means you're disloyal to the
government or something like that
Trump is foolish to fall into this right
on the one hand this is idiocy hey if
you're not endangering anybody or not
endangering anybody and if you're young
and healthy and you don't have this
thing then you're not endangering
anybody and no president Trump really
does not have to wear a mask because we
know he doesn't have it he's being
tested like every single day and he's
the most monitored person on planet
earth and also he has apparently been
wearing than ask behind the scenes when
he has been in close contact with people
but on the one hand you have the people
who are like if you don't wear a mask
you're just loyal American you're a very
bad person
on the other hand you have people who
are like I'm never wearing a mask ever
because if I wear a mask then it just
shows that I am bowing to government
authority or how about this how about
you trust in Americans to be reasonable
this is why as the social fabric has
decayed this this gap really does
demonstrate how people have
filled the gap in social fabric with
desire for government intervention ISM
see here's the thing I trust my
neighbors and I trust my friends that
they're not going to endanger me I do in
fact our synagogue put out a statement
yesterday about how they're gonna reopen
and the way they're gonna reopen is no
Kadesh meaning that people are not going
to be eating and drinking and buffet
lines but that they are going to
socially distance the table six feet
that you are supposed to wear a mask at
all times during Dominic right all of
these things are voluntarily being
undertaken they're not being undertaken
as in as an aspect of the government
order and why because we all trust each
other we don't wanna get each other sick
but as the social fabric has decayed
people want the government to to enforce
all this stuff and then you get people
who are cracking back at that same Co
I'm never listening to the government
ever okay what if like both things are
bad what if what if the government
should not be mandating the masks but we
should have a social fabric in which we
trust each other enough not to be idiots
to each other how about that so Joe
Biden came out he said that Donald Trump
is a fool for not wearing a mask which
of course is ridiculous got Ralph
Northam wasn't wearing a mask Joe Biden
in this particular interview with CNN
isn't wearing a mask like this is here
in certain situations you should wear a
mask if you're walking into an old-age
home you should be tested and you should
wear a mask and um and if not if you're
like out in public and a hundred feet
from people you shouldn't wear a mask
this is silly the fool an absolute fool
to talk that way I mean every leading
doc in the world is saying we should
wear a mask when you're in a crowd and
especially when you know you're going to
be in a position where you're going to
inadvertently get closer than twelve
feet to somebody I know we're twelve
feet apart I get that but it's just
absolutely this this macho stuff that
for a guy I shouldn't get going but it
just is it's cost people's lives okay
the reason this is bad politics for
Trump and it's smart politics for Biden
honestly is because particularly the the
soccer moms from 2004 the the security
moms who are very worried about
terrorism therefore voted for george w
bush what makes them feel safer a
president who is taking seriously the
virus to the extent that he's being /
serious or president who's being
cavalier and treating it as a sign of
masculinity like just on a political
level this is not pretty
really smart like so yesterday president
Trump was calling a reporter politically
correct for wearing a mask now he's not
wrong that the reporter is virtue
signaling by wearing a mask when the
Bert when the report is far away from
everybody I mean that part is true but
the question is why is this the image
that he wants to project like why that's
an important thing to do
they're inside they don't wear masks and
so I thought it was very unusual that he
had one on but I thought that was fine I
wasn't criticizing him at all why would
I ever do a thing like that
and your second question was I couldn't
hear you can you take it up because I
cannot hear I'll just speak louder sir
okay good you want to be politically
correct go ahead no sir I just want to
wear the mask okay okay so and there's
the president ripping into masks worth
why he would allow this to become
political is beyond me it's just it's
political malpractice but we've seen a
lot of political malpractice this week
by the way the media are indeed
hypocrites on this particular issue the
best clip of yesterday was an MSNBC
reporter trying to shame people around
him for not wearing masks and a person
in Wisconsin not wearing a mask
immediately turns him and says your
cameraman is not wearing a mask it was
pretty spectacular the people they're
just not worried about it
Calla they're not worried about their
own personal safety anybody who is you
can see here just rough nobody's wearing
them nobody's striking images of the guy
just owning MSNBC with facts and logic
right there by the way the hypocrisy
exists on all sides up all this is so
annoying cuz it's so stupid
it surely is I really feel like 85% of
Americans are on the same page here
which is be responsible socially in a
sense
wear a mask when you have to and get
back to work protect the elderly like
what why is this why is this
unreasonable I'm so confused as to how
this has become such a wildly partisan
issue except that everything now is
about signaling everybody and it's not
even virtue signaling it's about
commitment siglo signaling and that's
why I'm gonna get to in a second is this
commitment signaling routine that we get
on Twitter because in our age it's not
even about your signaling your virtue or
your signaling your beliefs is your
signaling your loyalty to a particular
person or particular cause and if you're
signaling loyalty without virtue loyalty
without virtue is it is it not a merit
it is a demerit
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that right now if you look in it your
business it is very important that you
be right on top of your data what you
need is NetSuite by Oracle the world's
number one cloud business system finance
HR inventory e-commerce everything you
need all in one place you save time
money and headaches whether you're doing
a million or hundreds of millions in
sales
NetSuite will give you visibility and
control so you can manage every penny
with precision joint over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence NetSuite surveyed
hundreds of business leaders assemble
the playbook of the top strategies they
are using as America reopens for
business this would be a terrible time
to stumble blindly through the business
minefield that is the modern economy
receive your free guide seven actions
businesses need to take right now and
schedule your free product tour at
NetSuite calm slash appear again this is
gonna keep your business running
smoothly
keeping it functional operational get
rid of that hairball of systems that
doesn't keep you updated on your data
regularly get your free guide schedule
your free product you'll right now at
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro that is
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro n ETSU ite
dot-com slash up here oh that's NetSuite
dot-com slash apparel go check them out
right now and again get that free guide
seven actions businesses need to take
right now and schedule that free
products we're at NetSuite calm slash
appear okay so my big question continues
to be how all of this has gotten so
partisan because again I think that
everybody is sort of ending up in the
same place which is be reasonable and
Democrats in their own actions are being
more reasonable than they are in their
rhetoric so take for example Brechin
Whitmer so Gretchen Whitmer was like
shut it all down you can't buy seeds at
the local store you can't you can't buy
a baby seat and then her husband was
like headed off to their second property
and calling up calling up boat houses
and telling him to load his boat in the
lake from Memorial Day and all of this
and Gretchen Whitmer was trying to deny
that yesterday the the very strict
lockdown governor of Michigan who is
cramming down all of her silly
restrictions on the people of Michigan
because she can't trust them but you
can't trust her husband here's Whitmer
my husband made a failed attempt at
humor last week when checking in with
the small business that helps with the
airboat and dock up north knowing it
wouldn't make a difference he jokingly
asked of Marian if being married to me
might move him up in the queue obviously
with the motorized boating prohibition
in our early days of Cove in nineteen he
thought it might get a laugh it did
and to be honest I wasn't laughing
either when it was related to me yeah
I'm sure it was a joke or alternatively
he was trying to call in and be a big
shot and get the rules broken for him so
good good times here by Democrats again
everybody is a human being here
underneath all of the politics
everybody's a human being we're all
gonna end up individually assessing our
risks and then acting accordingly that's
where we're gonna end up and that's not
a bad thing that's a good thing that's a
very good thing and by the way it's not
just happening here it's happening in
Europe as well right all of this is like
human beings acting responsibly I
thought that that was the predicate for
virtually all republic behavior and
republic we have to trust each other
enough to act responsibly okay but be
everything that has become politicized
because everything now is about
commitment signaling and this is really
the key when it comes to masks its
commitment signaling how committed are
you to the mask I'm so committed to the
mask that I mask when I'm alone in my
bathroom at night in my house that's how
committed to masks I am how committed
are you deliberately I'm so committed to
Liberty then I'm gonna go into a giant
crowd of a thousand people I'm just
gonna breathe on everybody just breathe
on everybody to prove Liberty is any of
this virtuous is any of this moral is
any of this decent or is just about
commitment signaling so a perfect
example of commitment signaling happened
yesterday online over this idiotic
situation in Central Park
so there's a woman her name is Amy
Cooper and she is apparently a lifelong
Democrat which by the way you could
absolutely tell from all of the outside
indicators here okay because if you
watch this watch this little clip that
went viral yesterday and the day before
there's a woman named Amy Cooper and
then there's a dude named Christian
Cooper okay they are not related because
one is white one is black and Amy Cooper
is in the park walking her dog through a
place called the ramble which is
apparently like this bird-watching
sanctuary and Christian Cooper gets mad
because the the dog is there and
Christian Cooper according to his own
account basically says to the lady put
your dog on a leash and she says I don't
want to put the dog on a leash because
they've shut down all of the areas where
my dog can run around and he says well
if you don't put your dog on the leash
if you're gonna do what you're gonna do
then I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do and
you're not gonna like it which is a
tacit threat obviously I mean that
doesn't sound exactly like he's gonna
pet the dog does he okay and then he
signals that her dog should come over
and he takes some doggy treats out of
his pocket he doesn't have a dog and
he's taking doggy treats out of his
pocket at that point she loses it and
she says a racist thing shows
up the NYPD I'm gonna tell them an
african-american man is threatening my
life not sure why exactly the race is
relevant there except that as a good
liberal who gave money to Barack Obama
she probably thinks the NYPD are a bunch
of vicious racists are gonna come and
shoot the black guy right that is it
that is probably the underlying message
there so she says the racist thing then
she calls the cops and she says there's
an african-american man threatening me
and then he takes this tape and he puts
it online and then she gets fired now
there's no evidence she worked at some
sort of financial firm no evidence that
she's ever been racist in her career no
evidence that that her financial career
has been motivated and played by bigotry
she lost her job over all of this and
she was you know her and and people
people weren't tweeting there their
commitment to it and there's this basic
idea that if you tweeted that this woman
was bad you demonstrated your commitment
it wasn't commitment to virtue it was
just her commitment to the cause no
getting her fired is not actually virtue
it having the woman's dog removed from
her and getting her fired that seems
pretty crappy honestly now I'm not a dog
owner so I really can't speak - is she
really mistreating the dog in the
particular tape she's holding the dog by
the collar as it kind of struggles
against her so I don't know the answer
to that but the idea of the woman ought
to lose her job because there's a guy
who took a video of her and he was not
acting wonderfully and then she says
something racist how is that like the
best outcome how is this how is this a
good outcome and the answer is on
Twitter and in social media and in our
political lives right now it's all about
the level of commitment you are willing
to signal so if you so it's not enough
to just say wow this woman's had a
racist thing that's bad instead it's
let's find her home address and let's
send for mail let's go outside her house
let's go through her business and let's
make sure she loses her job and her
livelihood because I've demonstrated to
all of you through my commitment to the
cause just how committed I am and all it
took was a few clicks of the keys and
everything was great my commitment
signaling is SuperDuper strong according
to the New York Times and the woman has
now been viewed 30 million times this
video touching off intense discussions
about the history of false accusations
made to the police against black people
sometimes putting their lives in danger
she has given up her dog publicly
apologized and been fired from her job
even Christian Cooper was like I'm sorry
that this has been the extent of the of
the blowback Christian Cooper was like I
feel like this is not actually the way
this should have gone he appeared with
with Anderson Cooper yesterday and he
was laid on
rather and he was like I feel like this
is over-the-top guys like all I meant to
do is kind of shame the lady a little
bit and instead everybody decided to
demonstrate their commitment by getting
her fired some of the messaging I am
told has been death threat and that is
wholly inappropriate and abhorrent and
should stop immediately
um if I find the strange that people who
were upset that they tried that as they
see it and and rightly that she tried to
bring death by cop down on my head would
then turn around and try to put death
threats on her head where is the logic
in that where does that make any kind of
sense okay by the way the the notion
that she in the actual call there is a
difference in what she says to him and
what she says to the police in the
actual agency or make the police call in
the police call she says he's
threatening my dog in what she says to
him is you're threatening me he said
presumably there'd be a difference in
response by the police to those two
things but in any case even he says
Christian Cooper he says correctly if
our goal is to change the underlying
factors I'm not sure this young woman
having her life completely torn apart
serves that goal and that is exactly
correct I mean that's exactly right but
again everything has now become about
commitment signaling and you're seeing
this with regard to you president Trump
on Twitter as well we'll get to that
momentarily none of this is good for the
country it really is not your commitment
demonstrating your commitment to the
cause on Twitter does not make you a
better person it doesn't it doesn't make
you morally superior doesn't make a
decent in fact it makes you very
indecent if you are committed to the
cause to the extent that you were doing
an immoral thing to demonstrate your
commitment to the cause then that just
makes you a radical and listen extremism
and pursuit of Liberty is no vice
but extremism in the pursuit of
stupidity is a definite vice extremism
in the pursuit of demonstrating your
commitment and loyalty to a particular
cause without any decency attached to it
doesn't make you a better person you saw
that happen in this case and as we will
see this also happened with regard to
Twitter and president Trump yesterday
and it's just it's ugly and it's dumb
and it's all reactionary yeah we're
gonna get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that right now would be a great time to
consolidate that credit card balance
because you can't afford to be paying
off these debts at 20% interest rates
right now you get a rate as low as five
point nine five APR with Auto pay much
lower than the national average credit
card rate of over 19
and APR when you go and use light stream
there are no fees the application is
quick and easy it is 100% online you can
even get your money as soon as the day
you apply light stream believes people
with good credit deserve a better loan
experience that is exactly what they
deliver customers are saying when
they've been listening to the podcast
and they've been going to light stream
they've been consolidating their debt
and they've been ensuring that they're
paying a lower APR that is very good
news that's something that is
financially responsible applied today to
get a special interest rate discount and
save even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash appear oh that is lig HT stre am
comm slash apparel light stream comm
slash Shapiro go check them out right
now subject to credit approval rate
includes 0.50% auto pay discount terms
and conditions apply offers are subject
to change without notice
visit light stream comm slash Shapiro
for more information and get that
special discount that I've talked to you
about again light stream comm /pl be
financially responsible okay so we're
gonna get to more of the more of the
commitment signaling that we are seeing
across media it's just yeah we're gonna
get to that in just a second first let's
talk about the fact that everybody loves
leftist you're similar everybody loves
this thing in fact people love it so
much they want to of them well now you
could kit you have two hands therefore
you need two leftist years summer and
you can get two of them it is only
available for our most exclusive that
memberships here are all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
it's our brand-new interactive
programming featuring one of us daily
wire host as we hang out with you each
night all access members also get to
join us for real-time Q&A discussions
available on both the website and the
daily wire app the all-access lies by
the way are a lot of fun people really
really enjoy them I have a bevy of new
t-shirts to sport for you on the
all-access live we did one last night
and it was kind of a kick there were
Chris Matthews impersonation so if you
missed those then you can get your Chris
Matthews impersonation fix over there I
believe yesterday Chris Matthews
actually did the hook rant in about
about the downsides of having children
yeah it gets real weird all-access
membership now includes two of the
irreplaceable leftist ears tumblers
which are literally overflowing with
tears at the thought of this offer and
by literally I mean figuratively
finally all access members also get the
benefits of our membership tiers
including add free website experience
access to the live broadcast and show
library access to the shows mailbags the
full three hours
of the ben shapiro show along with
dedicated editorials from moi if you're
not an all-access member you are missing
out head on over to daily wire.com at
slash subscribe to join all access you
get 15% off with coupon code shapiro
right now that is daily where dot-com /
subscribe we'll see you there also
tonight we have a backstage from our
socially distance hidey-holes 4 p.m.
Pacific 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time
so that's gonna be a party for you not
for me I have to hang out Noel's but for
you it'll be a party if you go and
subscribe right now daily wire comet
slash subscribe join on access you get
the two tumblers and 15% off with coupon
encoded Shapiro right now you're
listening to the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
okay so when we talk about commitment
signaling that one aspect of commitment
signaling is just doubling down on the
stupid crap you've said before right
that that's demonstrating your
commitment you never back off you never
apologize you never stop never stop
never stopping you just continue down
this road and the way this works is that
if the president for example if
President Trump decides that he's just
going to randomly accused you of
Scarborough of murdering a Catholic
Republican in turn twenty years ago and
she's gonna go off on this thing he's
gonna he's gonna suggest it by the way
this used to be a Democrat thing right
Michael Moore once suggested that Joe
Scarborough had murdered an intern
Marco's Miletus suggested Joe
Scarborough had murdered an intern so
recognized that the rumor actually
started on the left but Trump
repeating it is obviously immoral right
it is an immoral thing accusing people
of murder without evidence immoral
immoral when you're doing it to Rafael
Cruz and suggesting you kill John F
Kennedy immoral when you're doing it to
Joe Scarborough immoral do not accuse
people of murder also really really
immoral accusing a dead Catholic woman
of having been having an affair with a
congressperson and then being murdered
over the affair really really bad really
bad stuff guys okay look I don't care
who says this I don't care that you like
president Trump bad thing to do bad
thing to say and if you have a hard time
saying bad thing to do bad thing to say
get your priorities straight I'm not
saying you can't vote for the man I've
said before I'm intending on voting for
him but that is despite all this garbage
not because of all this garbage but
right now the way this works is that if
Trump says something unbelievably
terrible about the Joe Scarborough
intern situation if he continues to
double down on that and if you question
it then you are insufficiently committed
and this is one of the ugliest things
about our politics right now that you
have to demonstrate your commitment by
defending everything and and suggesting
well you know the media are constantly
attacking Trump I mean Scarborough said
nasty things about Trump so why
shouldn't he say nasty things about
Scarborough and the answer is what are
we in second grade here seriously like
it was in second grade we learned that
if somebody says something mean to you
the proper response is not to call their
mother a right this is like the
first thing that you learn when you are
a kid they if you have good parents your
parents teach you that just because that
other kid did something does not mean
that you also get to do that thing or do
it worse to them right that's not a
thing you get to do also there's
collateral damage here he's
just accusing Joe Scarborough slipping
puppies or something which would be you
know on its face ridiculous and and
silly you know he's actually accusing a
dead Catholic woman of having violated
her marital vows with Joe Scarborough
before being murdered okay that's really
bad stuff it is can we just acknowledge
this for a second but if you acknowledge
this you're insufficiently committed so
what president and what people love
about Trump for good or ill is that the
man is committed he's committed to him
to his own priorities apparently he's
not committed to political brilliance
because I I don't know who he is winning
over with this garbage now people are
like well he's not losing any votes with
it um yeah he is yes there are a bunch
of people who are let me tell you
Republican women in the suburbs do you
think they're showing up more or less
overall of the if you are a mascara
and if you are Jos car and if you're a
Catholic intern for Joe Scarborough
you're probably murdered by Joe
Scarborough
like is this have people forgotten that
politics is about demonstrating to
voters that you are fit to be President
demonstrating to voters two things one
the other guys unfit to you are fit
Trump is great at the former and awful
at the latter and if you if you want him
to win reelection he needs to stop this
bull crap right now now I've already
talked about the morality but you found
a political level okay but again we live
in a world where you're supposed to
demonstrate your commitment to the cause
by neglecting the evils on your own side
and pretending that they're okay or you
are supposed to or you're supposed to
sort of laugh at it as though it's a
joke or you're supposed to blame Joe
Scarborough for Trump accusing a dead
Catholic woman of being an adulteress
just okay so here was president Trump
yesterday defending his claim about
scarborough's in turn I'm sure that
ultimately they want to get to the
bottom of it and it's a versary
situation I also saw a clip with with
Joe and Imus where they were having a
lot of fun at her expense and I thought
it was totally inappropriate now it's a
very suspicious thing and I hope
somebody gets to the bottom of it it'll
be a very good thing as you know there's
no statute of limitations so it would be
a very good very good thing to do okay
meanwhile Joe Scarborough of course went
on the air last night and he pointed out
that Lorri Claussen says who is then
that's the name of the instrument I'd
that she was a
lifelong Republican and faithful
Catholic again you can like Scarborough
you can hate Scarborough but Scarborough
ain't wrong about this good woman a
young woman's desire to do something
good for the country that she has loved
has led first to people on the far left
on the Internet slowly in her name and
then a republican senatorial candidate
years later sullying her name and then
people on the far left later selling her
name and now the President of the United
States sullying
this good woman's name so we can point
out all this is bad that's okay your lab
or lab doesn't mean you have to vote for
Biden doesn't mean you have to not vote
for Trump you're allowed to say this is
bad stuff but commitment signaling means
you must never ever do that meanwhile
Twitter itself is engaged in commitment
signalling so Twitter has to demonstrate
to the left that they really really hate
from now here's the thing if you're on
the Left I don't know why in the world
you'd want Trump's Twitter voice
silenced seriously if you're on the Left
what you want is Trump tweeting this
crap every single day like Joe Biden is
celebrating he's doing a little dance or
as much as he can pick his feet up off
the ground these days he's doing a
little dance in his basement
every time Trump does this sort of stuff
but the media yesterday we're suggesting
that Trump should be removed from
Twitter Don Lemon was suggesting that
Twitter is a cesspool that has not held
Trump accountable
again it's not Twitter's job to hold
Trump accountable guess whose job that
is that's everybody else's job just like
they hold your Biden accountable but
again it's commitment signaling you
can't just say that Trump did a bad
thing you have to demonstrate how
committed you are to hating Trump by
saying that Trump should be removed from
Twitter so this is one of the media
again blow it so everybody's blowing it
on all sides it's unbelievable nobody
has fundamental sale like nobody has any
common sense sale is the it'sh word for
common sense nobody's any common sense
at all so you get the members of the
media or our Pro free speech everybody
gets to speak their opinion except for
Trump if he says a crappy thing you
should ban him from Twitter why how
would that how would that make things
better to ban him from Twitter I mean it
gives down lemon something to talk about
and by the way I think the American
people are smart enough to figure out
whether they like Trump's Twitter or not
here's Don Lemon yesterday
stop companies like Jack Dorsey and all
stop hiding behind the First Amendment
and it for profit stop doing it do the
right thing stop allowing families like
this family to have to go through this
to grieve their loved one over and over
and over and over again so they are
letting the president use their platform
to drag us all right into the mud no no
no no because this is that the media
just being terrible at their dumps to
Twitter of course because they do have
to commitment signal F to commitment
that is signaled their commitment to
fighting Trump so how do they do that so
they do that by taking down his tweets
about the scarborough intern no instead
they decide they're gonna put fact
checks on his tweets not only are gonna
put fact checks on his sweets they're
gonna be wrong okay so uh so yesterday
Twitter according to Reuters for the
first time prompted readers to check the
facts in tweets sent by President Trump
warning readers his claims about mail
and balance were false and had been
debunked by fact checkers the blue
exclamation mark notification prompted
readers to get the facts about mail and
balance and directed them to a page with
news articles and information from fact
checkers about his claims trumpet claims
in tweets earlier in the day mail and
balance would be substantially
fraudulent and result in rigged
elections he singled out the Governor of
California over the issue Twitter said
this was the very first time and it
applied a label to a tweet by the
president under its new misleading
information policy which had been
introduced earlier in the month there's
only one problem
there's only one problem they were wrong
the fact check was incorrect according
to all a pundit at hot air they are
instead of fact-checking like he killed
his intern routine they decided to fact
check the mail and ballot stuff and
they're wrong okay click the fact check
link in the tweets according to Ala
pundit you're sent to a page which
claims among other things that fact
checkers say there's no evidence mail-in
ballots are linked to voter fraud that
is not true as for an NPR story from
early April election experts say Trump
is partially correct that there is
slightly more fraud in mail voting mail
voting than in an in-person voting the
same experts told NPR election fraud is
extremely rare in all instances but it
is not true that there's no evidence
that mail-in ballots are linked to voter
fraud in fact yesterday yesterday there
was an actual case filed by the US
Attorney for the Northern District of
West Virginia in which a letter carrier
was charged
election fraud related to mail-in
request for primary ballots yesterday
the mail and primary ballot request
appeared to have been part of a state
plan to send an absentee ballot request
to everyone in West Virginia during the
novel coronavirus pandemic the postman
defendant Thomas Cooper faces one count
that's according to court documents
obtained by law and crime he even
admitted to altering some of the
requests so at the same time the twitter
is claiming there's no evidence of
mail-in ballots being fraudulently used
or obtained the federal government is
filing a case against somebody for doing
just that
so Twitter's fact-checking again
everybody's incompetent everybody's
terrible twitter is fact-checking and
using the wrong fats which is incredible
by the way if you're gonna fact-check
things it turns out that Twitter it
needs to fact-check its own site
integrity head there's a person named
Yolo Roth he is the head of Twitter's
fact-checking team there's only one
problem your Roth has tweeted about how
Trump was a Nazi he suggested that he is
Joseph Goebbels he Comerica he met Kelly
on Conway's he Joseph Goebbels the Nazi
propagandist so are they gonna fact
check his tweets so obviously this
opened the way to President Trump going
after Twitter so now we have Trump
versus Twitter which again is a better
battle for Trump then then Trump versus
Joe Scarborough is dead in turn but does
it lead to any sort of principled
outcome no now we're gonna get
commitment signaling on behalf of Trump
that is anti free speech which is just
mind boggling
so Trump is objecting to the fact that
people are saying that people should
take down his tweets or fact-check his
tweets I agree
Twitter should not be fact-checking his
tweets if you want a fact check his
tweets you have the Google machine do it
yourself if you want to check the fact
checkers the fact checkers have all the
information out there people are
tweeting about it that's what Twitter is
for it's a fulsome engagement with
various points of view but president
Trump responds to this by saying you're
trying to censor me on Twitter well what
if I just shut down Twitter entirely
what if I President of the United States
simply shut down the social media
company say tweets out Republicans feel
that social media platforms totally
silence conservative voices we will
strongly regulate or close them down
before we can ever allow this to happen
we saw what they attempted to do and
failed in 2016 we can't let a more
sophisticated version of that happen
again just like we can't let large-scale
mail in ballots take root in our country
it would be a free-for-all on cheating
forgery and the theft of ballots whoever
cheated the most would win likewise at
social media clean up your act now so
now he's threatening as president of
United States to take down Twitter to
take down Facebook and by the way he's
doubling down on it again like he visit
this morning he's just on a rampage on
all of this and now in order to
demonstrate your commitment to
demonstrate your commitment it is now
necessary that you backed president
Trump basically calling for the end of
social media he says he says Twitter has
now shown that everything we've been
saying about them and their other
compete rates is correct big action to
follow okay now I agree that Twitter is
really bias I agree that Jack Dorsey is
a terrible CEO I agree with all of those
things I don't know why it's the role of
the government to shut down Twitter that
seems like a very dangerous thing does
it not to you how would you like the
idea of the left just shutting down talk
radio cuz they don't like the voices
that are being disseminated on it or
how'd you like the return of the
Fairness Doctrine what's good for the
goose is good for the is good for the
gander by the way Trump again this
morning was going after Joe Scarborough
he's a psycho Joe Scarborough is rattled
not only by his bad ratings but all of
the things in facts that are coming out
on the internet about opening a whole
case he knows what is happening what the
actual what the actual okay everything
is terrible
everything is stupid and everyone is
stupid that's it this is the short
conclusion also do not be a commitment
signal or instead signal virtue or just
be virtuous how about that you're not
signal anything just be virtuous just be
decent why is any of this difficult I'm
so confused as to why any of this is
difficult
be responsible don't be a jackass really
not hard stick to a commitment to
principles not a commitment to follow a
particular person down the primrose path
or follow a particular cause so far that
you are indecent and and nasty and
pursuing it but apparently again it's
it's never about the truth anymore and
never about decency yeah yeah yeah okay
time for a bevy of things that I hate
already so a very variable Conant of
cornucopia of things that I hate today
so many things to hate so President
Trump announced today that the United
States is going to be bringing back our
soldiers from Afghanistan so that means
we've been there for 19 years and the
Taliban is gonna take over so that went
great so I'm glad that we went into
Afghanistan to stop the Taliban from
taking over because the Taliban had
provided a safe haven for al Qaeda which
resulted in 9/11 and now we are just
going to hand the country back to the
Taliban is apparently the plan so that's
really bad stuff I know a lot of people
are saying that war is is useless that
that war is not a good idea and that war
has been a failure the reality is the
Terrorism from Afghanistan has radically
reduced since we took the Taliban out of
place simply putting the Taliban back in
is full-on crazy I mean the and that's
basically what we are talking about
doing right now I'm old enough to
remember when everybody sort of agreed
that that was the good war that that was
that the good war was fighting the
Taliban and Afghan was the bad war right
because there was no terrorism coming
from Iraq and WMD and all that but now
the now the idea is that Afghanistan is
the bad war according to the New York
Times senior military officials are set
to brief President Trump in the coming
days on options for pulling all of
American troops out of Afghanistan with
one possible timeline for withdrawing
forces before the presidential election
according to officials with knowledge of
the plans now remember this was Barack
Obama's policy and I'm old enough to
remember when Republicans were like wait
you're handing the country back to the
Taliban that seems like a bad idea
I'm old enough to remember when people
were angry that Obama was negotiating
directly with the Taliban via Kuwait I'm
old enough to remember that because I'm
at more than five years old
but apparently when Trump does it it's
now okay it is not okay it is bad it is
stupid the fact is General David
Petraeus suggests that you at least have
to keep a skeleton force on the ground
to prevent the fall of the government
and the restoration of the evil Taliban
regime which would immediately become a
safe haven for terrorism again they plan
to propose an advocate a slower
withdrawal schedule but again when you
present Trump of the fast schedule and a
slow schedule likely the Trump takes the
fast schedule in recent months Trump has
repeatedly voiced a desire to leave
Afghanistan sooner than the timeline
laid out in the February twenty-ninth
peace agreement with the Taliban which
stipulated that US troops would leave in
12 to 14 months if the insurgent group
met certain conditions the Pentagon is
expected to try and persuade the
president that he
should basically take this a lot slower
the debate highlights the mounting
difficulty facing the February agreement
political strife and bloody Taliban
attacks have derailed what little
progress has been made since the deal
signing because it turns out that the
Taliban have no intention of keeping
it's a deal
the Taliban intend on fully coming in
and is murdering everybody who
cooperated with the United States which
would just be another wonderful example
of the United States interfering in the
Middle East with good intentions and
then basically leaving people to die
which is exactly what the United States
said to the Kurds in 1991 after the Gulf
War it was really great
I don't I don't know honestly if you're
if you're a person who is fighting
tyranny on the ground in any of these
countries can you trust the United
States of the United States and pleased
with withdraws and just lets you you
know take take the hit I'm not sure why
people would do this
that's what Vietnam was - by the way it
was about literally hundreds of
thousands and millions of people
cooperating with the United States the
United States leaving and those people
just being left to the tender mercies of
the Vietcong it turns out that where
America's boots go liberty follows and
we're america's boots withdraw Liberty
recedes at least before you've
established something that is workable
and we're not talking about hundreds of
thousands of fruits in Afghanistan right
now we're talking about maintaining a
status quo and that's kind of important
it is I understand that everybody wants
the troops home I would love the troops
home - it's not that anybody's a war
monger here nobody's in favor of
starting a new war nobody's talking
about ramping up the troop presence to
hundreds of thousands of troops but to
remove all tenuous gains that have been
made in Afghanistan in order to signal
to the American public that you're tired
of this is not actually good policy
whether again if whoever Barack Obama
would be saying exactly the same thing
and I did you can go back and listen to
it and so there's that meanwhile on
foreign policy
the State Department is announcing Mike
Pompeo has announced that Hong Kong can
no longer be considered separate and
autonomous from China which basically
means that China has now taken over Hong
Kong okay which is an incredible
incredible demonstration that when the
West does not stand up to tyranny then
the tyrants take over according to
Bloomberg the US has certified that Hong
Kong is no longer politically autonomous
from China a move that could have
far-reaching consequences on the special
trading status the former British colony
has with the United States according to
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo this of
course comes in the aftermath of the
Chinese government using the pandemic as
an excuse to go in and quash all dissent
inside
Kong it comes after 20 years of the
Chinese government basically violating
every abrogating every element of the
treaty and had with the British
government the British government
withdrew from Hong Kong in 1997 the
basic deal was that Hong Kong would
still be allowed to have an autonomous
government even if it worked in close
cooperation with the Chinese who'd be
allowed domestic rule and instead the
Chinese government just ignored it and
they understood that there would be no
consequences for doing so because what
exactly was Britain gonna do reoccupy
this is why it is always an invariably
an idiotic idea to withdraw from places
in favour of a tyrannical regime and
trust that their commitments are going
to be kept so the people of Hong Kong
have now been put directly under the
thumb of the Chinese government if you
have any sympathy for the people of Hong
Kong you should recognize how evil it is
what the Chinese government is doing
I mean Hong Kong no longer being
politically autonomous from China is
said the people in in Taiwan have to be
looking over their shoulders at this
point right I mean China claims
sovereignty over Taiwan Taiwan is a
United States ally and the Chinese
government's been threatening hong kong
continuously so china continues even as
they unleashed a pandemic on the rest of
the world they continue to exacerbate
their political control over the region
there better be some harsh consequences
here and I mean serious economic harsh
consequences against the government of
China and if the media feel the
necessity to back China just because
President Trump is anti China I think
they're demonstrating full-scale their
actual priorities okay other things that
I hate today
so I guess that we are now going to
reduce everything to the racial because
again very important to signal your
commitment to particular causes as I've
said yesterday when it came to issues of
race I think that we can all agree the
racism still exists in the United States
that instances of racism are evil that
we can all condemn them and then we
should all be on the same side when it
comes to this sort of stuff it is also
true that we are now doing a routine
where we are in hunt for instances of
racism now instances of racism
absolutely exist I did that situation in
Central Park look like an instance of
racism it did in the we've had we've had
shootings and killings that have looked
like instances of racism you know it
doesn't seem like an instance of racism
to me Jimmy Fallon dressing up as Chris
Rock in 2000 on SNL I'm sorry it doesn't
it doesn't seem like an instance of
racism you know who else it didn't seem
like an end
racism to anyone at SNL or anyone for
the prior 20 years it turns out by the
way that if you don't like Jimmy Fallon
dressing up in as Chris Rock then you
should also not like Jimmy Kimmel
dressing up his Karl Malone but but
Jimmy Kimmel is the woke Pope and so he
is granted absolution despite the fact
that by the way Jimmy Fallon's
impression of Chris Rock was
significantly less offensive than Jimmy
Fallon's impression of Karl Malone his
impression of Karl Malone was basically
playing Karl Malone as a as a
stereotypical ugly awful dumb I mean it
was it was really bad it was really bad
did you mean go back and watch the Jimmy
Kimmel tape that one actually looks a
lot more racist the Jimmy Fallon one
he's playing Chris Rock and again I
think it's important to recognize here
that there are in fact traditions one
Williams told me this on on the show a
couple of years ago when we discussed
this and he was right there are
gradations in terms of how bad it is to
dress up as a black person right there
is dressing up in full scale blackface
stereotypical fashion 1920s you're
mocking black people as as shiftless and
dumb and all that's ugly and horrifying
and has a history in slavery and Jim
Crow and all that and then there is you
dressed up as Michael Jackson in 1987
because you like Michael Jackson music
and that is not the same thing it's not
you may think that wasn't that that's
insensitive okay and in today's day in
world I wouldn't do it I don't think
people should do it
it's insensitive not the same thing for
Jimmy Fallon to dress up as Chris Rock a
specific human being with whom he has
friends again and and to treat that as
though he was dressed up in
quote-unquote blackface that's not the
same thing Jimmy Fallon said in 2000
while on SNL I made a terrible decision
to do an impersonation of Chris Rock
while in blackface there's no excuse for
this again blackface hasn't like an
actual meaning and putting on black
makeup is not the same as blackface
blackface hasn't like an actual meaning
and that was to dress up as a black
person in order to mock black people in
stereotypical awful and evil ways that's
not what Jimmy Fallon was doing when you
dressed up as Chris Rock
he says I'm very sorry for making this
unquestionably offensive decision thank
you all of you for holding me
accountable this is what we have to do
we have to do struggle sessions to
demonstrate full-on commitment to the
cause at this point instead of him
basically saying the same thing that
Sarah Silverman said by the way try and
spot a comedian in the last 20 years who
didn't do this seriously in the last 30
years Sarah Silverman did it Jimmy
Kimmel did it Jimmy Fallon's in it that
should speak to how it was perceived at
the time it was
perceived as mocking black people
because guess what racism was not in
vogue in 2000 it wasn't okay meanwhile
if you want to talk about actual
instances where race becomes an issue
then we can talk about this situation in
Minneapolis so if you haven't seen this
awful awful tape it really is bad
there's a tape of police officers on the
neck of a black perpetrator the the
perpetrator apparently was was doing
some sort of forgery and they caught him
doing a forgery in progress how do you
know how you do that okay but in any
case there's a forgery being reported
this guy was in his car he apparently
was committing the forgery then he got
out of the car and he confronted the
cops and who's resisting arrest okay so
at this point you subdue the person and
then you put them in the paddy wagon and
you take them to jail right mean that's
normally how this works instead a police
officer decided it would be a great idea
Smeal on the back of the neck of the
person and then the person died because
it turns out that you're not supposed to
kneel on the back of other human beings
now a couple of things as I always say
proof of incompetence stupidity and evil
does not mean proof of racism and that
there was a case out here in California
very very famous case in California not
famous nationwide in which there is a
white homeless man well his first name
was Kelly and I and I forgot his last
name and he was basically beaten to
death by the police his a white homeless
guy he was quasi resisting arrest but
not really
they started whaling on him and and he
died from it and this this was not
considered a nationwide story
specifically because it was about police
brutality and cruelty and and
incompetence and it wasn't about racism
when if he had been black then the story
would've been racism so the the guy's
name was Kelly Thomas
that's right Kelly Jones I remember his
big story out here okay that was not
considered a name worth remembering
obviously because he was white now the
question in this particular case in
Minneapolis is whether this is just
police incompetence or whether the
police officer was just a vicious racist
who decided to kill this guy because he
was black or took less of a care about
him because he was black and their riots
last night in Minneapolis Minneapolis
mayor then went out there and used
language that was extraordinarily highly
charged he suggested being black
shouldn't be a death sentence I'm not
aware that being black is a death
sentence in the United States in fact
statistically speaking it is absolutely
not a death sentence in the United
States but because
every instance of awful police work in
which there's white police officer in a
black person has to be perceived as an
indicator of broad-based American racism
and not as an indicator of police
officer sucking at their job and I know
lots of police officers who would look
at this and be absolutely horrified on
every level but instead this turns into
a racial debate even though again
there's not evidence that this was a
racial killing as opposed to the police
officers just a bad bad person and his
job at the very least being black in
America should not be a death sentence
for five minutes
we watched as a white officer pressed
his knee into the neck of a black man
for five minutes
when you hear someone calling for help
you are supposed to help this officer
failed in the most basic human sense
okay he did fail in the most basic human
sense that doesn't necessarily mean this
that was motivated by racism the only
reason that I point this out is that it
sort of seems important that if you're
going to suggest that race is the
motivating factor you provide some
evidence that raises the motivating
factor and I sort of like claims that
are backed by evidence also worthy of
note is there a single human being on
planet earth and well on planet Earth in
America are there very many human beings
there there's some overt racist people
really hate black people but are there
very many human beings in the United
States who if they found out that this
guy murdered a black man in cold blood
because he was a racist wouldn't want
this guy put on the electric chair
seriously like who's out there who
doesn't feel that way but there's an
attempt right now to suggest that
America again is rooted in racism and
viciousness Gayle King who again is
she's the anchor at CBS this morning she
suggested that that basically it is open
season on black men after racial
incidents it's open season it is not
open season on black men in America it
is not and if there's if there's a
racist incident we should all be on the
same side this is the commitment
signaling the commitments in the
narrative that America is deeply racist
in every way in every individual
instance every anecdotal piece of
evidence not data not like broad-based
data that's statistical in nature every
anecdotal piece of evidence is evidence
of that broad-based narrative that's
that is signaling your commitment to the
narrative it is not necessarily
signaling your commitment to the truth I
want truth and I want evidence and I
think that once the evidence comes out
we can all be on the same side because I
think that at root we all have the same
belief system here the same belief
system racism is bad policing competence
is bad murder is bad I feel like we're
all on the same page on these things
okay but there's an attempt to rush out
without the evidence and and I feel like
this is the case with so many of these
instances and it's not just with regard
to racism it seems like with regard to
everything these days there is a a
motivation to rush out and look at cases
where there is a deliberate lack of full
evidence make claims that stretch the
evidence in order to get to a conclusion
and then suggest that if you say well I
need to wait for the evidence that you
are insufficiently committed to the
cause that that's a problem it's a
problem because it actually robs us of
our ability
to agree on things that we all agree on
again I think we all agree racism bad
murder bad police incompetence bad right
we all agree on these things but if you
pick instances where the evidence is not
fully in on the racism aspect and you
then immediately call everybody who says
I'd like to see the evidence on that
insufficiently committed to the
anti-racist cause what you're actually
incentivizing is acting without evidence
in order to signal your commitment
commitment signaling needs to end
because if you are so committed to
commitment maybe you should be committed
all right we're gonna be here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content plus we have our
backstage live at tonight so go check us
out tonight subscribe for daily wire.com
become an all-access member of all sorts
of good stuff for you over there and
we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by Mike foramina hair and makeup
is by Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022 wierdos had a viral
meltdown in Central Park and now one of
their lives is ruined then for the first
time ever
Twitter fact checks President Trump on
voter fraud and for the seventh
zillionth time what Trump said turns out
to be true and the fact check turns out
to be a lie the mainstream media get
caught in more coronavirus hypocrisy and
in Washington State gunshot victims get
added to the Cova death tolls all that
and more check it out on the Michael
Nolt show
you